hi Johnny yes it is hello Gordon
unfortunately I have to eliminate to
rest of this competition you know this
competition it's about searching Britain
for the best restaurant and I fell in
love with nan gym from apartment I
walked in there whatever happens after
the phone call you've got to continue
for Nam gym it's been an amazing journey
today is where it comes to an end Jesus
don't listen I'm very very proud hello
yeah yes the competition is getting
harder and casimir congratulations
awesome there's a next day for
competition so no nothing seriously I
really one of them I were able to me the
more it sinks in ya before fantastic and
yeah it's just brilliant to feel
appreciated and given a chance to keep
go
so two brilliant restaurants remaining
the first time we final and I'm going to
pitch them both in a head-to-head battle
first I have a surprise in store
I'm about to drop in unexpectedly from
meal on a manga family-run Italian
restaurant Casimir from Bristol and
modern Spanish tapas restaurant fina
from London to help me decide who will
make it to the final I've enlisted to
trusted lieutenants for a second opinion
on strengths and weaknesses of these two
restaurants they got a stable 9c menu
press see angela hartnett one of the
most successful but a chef's of the last
15 years service and simon davies one of
the my secret diners an expert in
putting restaurants through their paces
they know the restaurant business inside
a house I trust their opinions
implicitly becomes my voice very
talented young individuals beware your
platform I'll in eatery that's going on
the first time I visited Casimir I found
their cooking to be new and exciting but
I discovered young chef john ray and
peter sometimes push things too far and
their experimental dishes can be hit and
miss you trying to be avantgarde you've
got to go with your customers you've got
to take every customer forward their
parents susan and pack o sang their life
savings into the restaurant but it says
sons had caught all the shots and cook
exactly what they want whether the
customer likes it or not I want to find
out what Angela and Simon think so we've
caught them on the whole how are you
very well welcome to Casa Mia hi guys
how are we how you doing how you both do
you expect us to do thank you haha some
days right before to see you often thank
you